well you know he could you could say
Napoleon was a bit like that I happen to
admire Napoleon a lot because he was
such a brilliant strategist I called him
I call him the Mozart of warfare he was
like a child prodigy with war and
strategy but you can divine Napoleon's
career into two halves for 10 years from
1796 to 1806 he was the absolute genius
from 1806 to 1816 at Waterloo and
everything he lost it all and it went to
his head his success went to his head
and instead of being enjoying the
process I tell people if you want to be
powerful in life you have to enjoy the
process you have to get pleasure out of
making the thing that you're making it
couldn't be can be politics there has to
be that kind of purpose behind it if
your purpose is simply gaining power if
you become kind of drunk on the
sensation that it gets you I'm not
making a moral judgment on it it's just
simply if that becomes your end in life
then you end up sort of destroying
yourself because you lose a sense of
distant attachment that's very necessary
you have to be detached a little bit
from other people so you can see what's
going on in the world if you're too
emotional you're going to lose it you
have to be detached from yourself you
have to be able to look at yourself with
some distance and some humor and some
irony you look at a person like Napoleon
and he had that for a while he was a
very clever person but he was also able
to criticize himself etc and then the
power and it just became too much and he
thought he was a god and he on the
battlefield he started losing it Stalin
you know is is it is a clear example but
you lose on a smaller scale we're
talking about giant egos like a Napoleon
or a Stalin on a smaller scale it
happens to everybody when you have any
kind of success in life that's like the
most dangerous moment that you're in
because you're going to tend to think
wow I can just keep repeating what I've
done I'm a great person people love me
all of a sudden they're giving me all of
this attention you get drunk on it
and you lose your sense of balance and
your sense of detachment I know it's
happened to me 15 years ago I was saying
the same things that I'm saying now but
nobody listened to me because I was
nobody now everybody thinks wow he's
saying this and that and what does that
mean and you can go to your head and you
can start thinking I'm infallible and
you have to drop that and you have to
step back and look at yourself and all
that so that's sort of how you could
become a Napoleon or a stall in and I
think celebrities have that kind of
complex
well you I mean you're giving me like a
pretty tough example you know somebody
wants did the same thing with the Israel
and Palestine like I'm going to be able
to solve that problem can give me a
break Kim Jong ill you know we're
dealing with these kind of closed
systems of power like the Soviet Union
was for many many years a world mostly
you put a group of people together and
politics intervenes I say put three
people together and they people become
political and they start thinking in
political terms you get a place like the
Soviet Union or North Korea these closed
systems it becomes completely political
it's not based on who's the smartest on
who has the most skill who's the best
leader to logically lead our country to
power and success it's all about these
little political games that people are
playing you can't enter that world from
the outside until people in North Korea
what to do a closed system like that I
used in the 48 laws of power i talked
about Athens and Sparta in ancient
greece athens was this very fluid
democratic capitalistic environment
Sparta was this closed world for
hundreds of years they tried to create
the system and they didn't want it to
change and eventually it just fell apart
on its own because you can't keep
something closed in this world north
Korea has to just fall apart like it
will eventually Kim jong-il will die
that somehow people will be Glee a level
of dissatisfaction you can't force
history that's sort of what we tried to
do in Iraq we'll see what happens many
people like myself years ago we're
predicting failure you can't force
history things like that have to come up
from below from the people themselves so
my advice unfortunately the people in
North Korea is to wait for when that
moment happens it's interesting to see a
place like Iran where it's really
happening now and it's very interesting
and very exciting where you have a group
of people are trying to put the lid on
change and on history
and a lot of very brave people are
trying to struggle and fight against
that because they've reached a level of
disgust they just can't stand it any
longer and so it's coming up from the
bottom I don't see any signs of that in
North Korea so it might be another fifty
hundred years who knows